okay on tuesday coinbase announced that
they will be launching an nft platform
and the waitlist group to over 1 million
users in just 24 hours
so uh here's the quote from the coinbase
announcement just as coinbase helped
millions of people access bitcoin for
the first time in an easy and trusted
way we want to do the same for nfts
right now openc is the largest nft
marketplace if you remember and
according to dap radar a site that
tracks decentralized app data openc had
261 000 users over the past 30 days so
um that seems like a small number in
terms of
you know the overall internet but i can
tell you for an early stage company like
an nft company to have a quarter million
people trading on the platform that
would be a huge number so i don't know
if that 261 thousand users actually made
a trade where they visited the site very
hard to tell from uh what the operator
is saying there so this is one of the
things that's always hard about metrics
in our industry people will say they had
users to me a user means they're logged
in so are these actually logged in users
or when i perused openc two or three
times last month am i counted
and then
were they not just logged in users but
did they actually do a transaction
because if they're users that means
maybe 10 did a transaction so it'd be 25
000 people making transactions and you
could actually work and back and forth
now for those of you don't know what an
nft is non-fungible token it's an object
typically like an image or a video
that is a keepsake that
could have some other rights associated
with it sometimes you buy it as a piece
of art sometimes you buy it to be part
of a club and a membership in a club and
maybe that membership will have some
downstream effects now people are
talking about them not just as baseball
cards or not just as a membership card
like you're in a private club like solo
house but maybe it's a has some utility
to it like it's a sword in a game and
you use it in
you know diablo but you can take the
same sword and use it in fortnite
perfect example and so
there is some concept of these nfts
these objects
obviously being tradable uh on the
blockchain being traded peer-to-peer
in an easy fashion and being one of one
and maybe even having rights to it so my
understanding is
uh i think with the board ape group you
get the rights to your monkey and you
can then make art with it or t-shirts i
believe that's the case either way
this uh nft waitlist means coinbase
is like great companies when they add a
vertical it's one of the great things
about having scale once you hit scale
you can add another adjacent category
you could be uber and you add uber eats
or uber freight now you're hitting the
ground running you've got some amount of
users technology team playbook
cash that you can deploy
to make it even faster and easier to do
the next vertical airbnb experiences
eventually airbnb they've talked about
having an airline each of those things
becomes easier
when you are amazon and have books and
then you do dvds and then you do home
appliances you get the idea and so and
robin hood obviously uh started drinking
coin bases milkshake and with their 20
million accounts
which obviously i have shares in robin
hood which if you had dinner with me
you'd know in the first 15 minutes and
those robin robin hood added crypto
right so now all of a sudden boom crypto
has become a meaningful part of what
they're doing so
there's a singularity that's occurring
all of these financial products will
have margin loans 401ks 529s for college
bank accounts checking
cash payments it's just going to all be
one thing so coinbase robinhood could
eventually be part of google amazon or
apple or be the equivalent of those
companies that's my belief i believe
coinbase and robin hood are destined to
become trillion dollar companies or be
a major piece of a trillion dollar
company how amazing would it be if your
amazon account was connected or your
apple account was connected to your
coinbase account and that was you know
coinbase was owned by apple or robinhood
was owned by apple what an amazing
future that would be right you're using
apple pay plus you've got your 401k and
your checking and your bank account
right here
i mean that would be extraordinary and
by the way you know the apple watch i
hated for a long time i got the six
because my fitbit kept breaking and i
was just tired of dealing with fitbit
customer support
literally every time i call fitbit
they're like yeah you're at a warranty
i'm like it's 18 months old this thing
is broken it just turned off like this
is the fourth time i've bought 20
fitbits and they're like yeah
sorry it's not under warranty and then i
go tweet it and i mention it because i
don't get the answer i want customer
support and then immediately seven
people dm me oh i work at fitbit we'll
send you a new one i'm just tired of
pulling the micro celebrity card on
twitter so i just bought an apple watch
and
i missed my fitbit i'll be honest i
liked it better
in many ways but the one thing i will
say is that when you double tap this or
just press this button and you can just
apple pay
oh my lord i am picking places to go
based on apple pay because
it's so delightful just go bank and then
get your little alert i was in italy
i was just buying it everywhere i loved
it and that i think is the future i
think we're gonna see google apple
facebook and amazon want to own one of
these companies or compete with them and
you see with apple pay google pay so
it's gonna be really interesting in
other news uh it's coinbase world we're
just living in it uh come back on the
program brian i want to talk uh in other
news we invited i know you guys keep
asking me to have brian back on we've
invited him 10 times we've got radio
silence right now so maybe i said
something i don't know sometimes i'm
honest candid or maybe he's just uh
tired of the press because the company's
doing so well he's super busy but i'd
love to have you back on brian and chop
it up
in other news uh cnbc reported on
tuesday that coinbase was facing
blowback on its new live customer
support phone service which they
launched this month obviously robin hood
announced they're launching 24-hour uh
seven-day-a-week phone support for their
31 million users wow they have 31
million users
oh wow co-robin according to the article
coinbase's phone support only deals with
customers whose accounts are locked uh
this is obviously useful for people
who've been hacked and hacking is the
big issue and cnbc
this week i don't know if you heard it
they went kind of all in with uh stories
of people who were hacked who lost all
their crypto
and this led to a lot of regulation talk
if this happens at a bank
you don't lose your money if it happens
at a crypto company sadly you do and so
if you want to trade
virtual money and you want to be a rebel
with your nfts and not have to report on
your taxes and do everything in the gray
area
well don't be surprised when you get
hacked and there's no recourse that's
the concept here it's decentralized
nobody's in charge oh
your money got stolen okay well why
don't you go to whoever's running this
decentralized network
it's like oh well it's a decentralized
network jkl nobody's running it okay so
you chose you chose to buy imaginary
money
and that imaginary money has no guard
rails you're screwed
buyer beware
you know people are taking their crypto
and putting it into safety deposit box
cold storage whatever if you're going to
do this and have any kind of money
you're probably going to want to be
across five different accounts and have
it locked
before we get into the ad i just want
you to go to linkedin.com twist right
now
linkedin.comtwist and post your first
job for free what a deal
incredibly supportive uh of you linkedin
to give that free job to our listeners
and you know small business owners are
busier than ever the time spent
searching for and interviewing wrong
candidates let's face it bad candidates
takes away from growing your business
that's why linkedin jobs has made it
easier to get the candidates worth
interviewing faster and they're giving
you your first job for free create a
free job post in minutes on linkedin
jobs to reach the world's largest
professional network of over 770 million
people use screening questions to get
your role in front of only the most
qualified people then quickly filter and
prioritize who you want to interview and
eventually hire we love linkedin jobs at
launch and inside and in 2021 we've
hired a third producer a curriculum
designer and a few more researchers and
we're doing all that hiring on linkedin
we love it and we're still hiring so
here is your call to action one more
time
linkedin jobs helps you find the right
candidates worth interviewing
faster every week nearly 40 million job
seekers visit linkedin so post your job
for free free f-r-e-e at
linkedin.comtwist that's right
linkedin.com twist to post your first
job for free terms and conditions do
apply because we're giving you something
for free all right let's get back to
this amazing episode